YOU'RE LOOKING LIVE AT FOX
SQUARE.
WE'RE DEBUTING THIS BLENDER SET
ON THE SPECIAL MIDTERM
REDUCTION OF THE FIVE.
>> HE IS:00 YOU'RE BUNDLED UP,
IT IS 55 DEGREES OUT HERE.
AS WANT THE AUDIENCE TO NOW,
ONLY 55 DEGREES.
GREG HAS DOUBLE LAYERS AND
THINK THAT YOU HAVE LEGWARMERS
ON, IS THAT CORRECT?
>> THIS IS AN ELECTRIC BLANKET.
>> 55 DEGREES.
>> YOU LOOK LIKE YOU'RE READY
FOR SPRING.
>> I AM READY!
>> JESSE WATTERS --
>> HE'S WEARING A LATEX
BODYSUIT UNDER THE SUIT.
>> YES.
>> HE REALLY WANTED TO WEAR
THAT BLUE SUIT SO HE SAID I'M
NOT GOING TO PUT A COAT OVER MY
COSTUME.
>> HE WAS GREAT ABOUT BEING OUT
HERE?
I HAVE A GREAT VIEW OF THE GAP.
>> YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT YOU NEED
TO BUY.
>> IS ALREADY A GREAT CROWD OUT
THERE.
>> OH YEAH!
>> WE LOST TO GET TO THE FIRST
-- A FOX NEWS ALERT WITH THE
HIGHLY ANTICIPATED MIDTERM
ELECTIONS JUST TWO DAYS AWAY,
THE PRESIDENT CONTINUING HIS
CAMPAIGN SCHEDULE.
THE PRESIDENT IS WRAPPING UP A
RALLY RIGHT NOW IN GEORGIA
BEFORE VENTING TO TENNESSEE
LATER TONIGHT.
HERE ARE SOME HIGHLIGHTS A FEW
MINUTES AGO.
>> REPUBLICANS PRODUCE JOBS,
DEMOCRATS PRODUCE MOBS.
[BOOING]
YOU HAVE HEARD THAT!
YOU HAVE SEEN IT!
YOU HAVE SEEN IT.
YOU HAVE SEEN IT AND -- THEY
TAKE THE HELMET OFF.
AND THEY TAKE THE ARMBANDS AND
YOU SEE THESE ARMS, THESE
LITTLE ARMS.
THE RADICAL RESISTANCE, THAT'S
WHAT THEY ARE, RADICAL
RESISTANCE.
TAKES POWER, THEY WILL MOVE
IMMEDIATELY TO REVERSE
AMERICA'S PROGRESS AND TO
ERADICATE ALL OF THE GAMES THAT
WE MADE.
IF YOU WANT MORE CRIME AND MORE
CARAVANS VOTE DEMOCRAT, IT'S
SIMPLE.
[BOOING]
IF YOU WANT STRONG VOTERS AND
SAFE COMMUNITIES, VOTE
REPUBLICAN.
>> GREGOR SECURELY TODAY, THE
PRESIDENT LED AN 2016 ON LAW
AND ORDER.
>> RIGHT.
>> THAT AS WELL WITH THE
MIDTERM HAS TURNED INTO.
>> TWO QUICK POINTS.
OF ALL THE PEOPLE CAMPAIGNING
ON BOTH SIDES, THE PERSON WHO
IS LEAST FATIGUED IS ORANGE
SUPERMAN.
IT IS AMAZING!
DID NOT NOTICE THAT ATLAS OR
PRESIDENT OBAMA OUT THERE AND
JOE BIDEN.
THEY LOOK WINDED AFTER JUST A
FEW APPEARANCES.
BUT IN TERMS OF ENERGY, THEY
ARE STILL THERE AND HE IS
NUCLEAR.
HE'S LIKE THE ROADRUNNER AND
EVERYONE IS EEYORE.
I WAS HAD 10 PERCENT OF THIS
ENERGY.
HAVING SAID THAT, I THINK THE
PROBLEM WITH LAW AND ORDER KIND
OF STANCE IS THAT IT CAN BE
PORTRAYED AS FEAR MONGERING.
THE PROBLEM IS, IT LOOKS LIKE
FEAR MONGERING BECAUSE WHAT YOU
WANT, IS A PROCESS.
AND THE OPPOSITE OF PROCESS IS
CHAOS.
SO IT IS A NATURAL INCLINATION
TO BE FEARFUL OF CHAOS.
I THINK THE PROPER FRAMING OF
WHAT DONALD TRUMP IS DOING IS
THAT WE ARE A PARTY OF PROCESS.
DUE PROCESS, LAW AND ORDER.
IF YOU THINK THAT IS FEAR
MONGERING THEN YOU'RE SADLY
MISTAKEN.
>> IS A PART OF THAT THOUGH IS
THE ECONOMY.
WE TALKED ABOUT STRONG ECONOMIC
NUMBERS I CANNOT FRIDAY.
EVEN THE POULTICE OVER THE LAST
THAT CAME OUT RIGHT BEFORE THE
ELECTION, 65 PERCENT OF PEOPLE
SAYING THAT THIS IS A GOOD
ECONOMY.
THE STRONG ECONOMY THAT HAS NOT
SHOWN UP IN THE POLLS.
HOWEVER, DO THINK IT WILL SHOW
UP AS A REASON PEOPLE VOTE ON
ELECTION DAY?
>> I DO.
I THINK THE SECOND BIGGEST
ISSUE IS ECONOMY FOR MOST
VOTERS.
HE COULD TELL THE PRESIDENT IS
EXTREMELY EXCITED.
YOU KNOW WHEN HE IS EXCITED AND
FEELING GOOD WHEN HE IS TALKING
ABOUT SKINNY ARMS ANTIFA.
ALSO REMINISCING ABOUT WHEN HE
WAS RUNNING IN THE PRIMARY
AGAINST REPUBLICANS.
HE WAS ALWAYS ON THE CENTER OF
THE STAGE.
YOU CAN TELL HE'S IN A REALLY
GOOD MOOD.
IT LOOKS LIKE AS YOU TALK
ABOUT, THE POLLS ARE REALLY
TIGHTENED.
AND EVEN THE PROGNOSTICATORS
ARE STARTING TO HEDGE.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE ABCNEWS
"WASHINGTON POST" POLL THE
CONGRESSIONAL GENERIC BALLOT
SHRUNK FROM 14 TO 11 AND NOW
DOWN TO SEVEN.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE OTHER
TWO THEY HAVE SEVEN AND FIVE.
IF YOU PLUG THE NUMBERS INTO
THE HISTORICAL PREDICTORS, IT
DOES NOT TRANSLATE INTO A
DEMOCRATIC VICTORY.
IT TRANSLATES INTO 15 SEATS TO
22 SEATS PICK UP.
NOT ENOUGH TO MAKE IT HAPPEN.
RIGHT NOW, THE REPUBLICANS ARE
FAVORED BY 10 AND 11 POINTS ON
THE ECONOMY.
AND ON BORDER SECURITY.
FAVORED BY FIVE ON TAXES WHERE
THEY ARE REALLY LOOKING BAD IS
HEALTHCARE.
THERE DOWN 15 POINTS ON
THAT IS THEIR FAULT, THEY
BOTCHED REPEAL AND REPLACE.
THEY ARE ALSO IN TROUBLE
BECAUSE EVERYONE RETIRED.
THEY THOUGHT THIS TO BE A
LANDSLIDE BLUE WAVE VICTOR PETE
ALL THESE GUYS AND RETARDS THE
REPUBLICANS ARE LOOKING AT A
LOCK RIGHT NOW.
AND SILVER HIS NOSTRIL TO
HEDGE.
HE SAID BEFORE, 45 CHANCES
DEMOCRATS TAKE THE HOUSE.
NOW THIS IS A DIRECT QUOTE.
EXTREMELY
EXTRPOELY
EXTRPOSSY
EXTRPOSSIBLE REPUBLICANS KEEP
THE HOUSE AND HOLES -- POLLS
CAN BE WRONG.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT WILL HAPPEN,
I WILL MAKE MY PREDICTION ON
TUESDAY AND YOU CAN TAKE THAT
TO THE BANK.
[LAUGHTER]
>> AT THE END WILL CALL THE
ELECTION.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> IS ONE OF THE CONCERNS FOR
DEMOCRATS THAT HAVE HIGH
EXPECTATIONS THEY CAN'T MEET?
>> NO I THINK YOU NEED TO MAKE
SURE PEOPLE GO OUT TO VOTE.
WHAT YOU REALLY TALK ABOUT HERE
IS TURNOUT.
AND EVERYBODY WANTS TO TURN
OUT.
WE'VE ALREADY SEEN IN TERMS OF
EARLY VOTING, IT IS HIGH
TURNOUT.
>> AND IN TEXAS, 4 MILLION
PEOPLE HAVE ALREADY VOTED.
>> CORRECT.
ESPECIALLY AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
HIGH LEVELS OF ENGAGEMENT.
YOU CAN VIEW THAT IN TERMS OF
LIKE YOU WERE DISCUSSING REESE
A HIGHER PERCENTAGE OF
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS IN
THE EARLY TURNOUT.
BUT IN OTHER STATES, GIVEN THE
HIGH LEVEL OF YOUTHFUL
ENTHUSIASM YOUR SEEING MORE
DEMOCRATS.
I THINK WE'RE SEEING A LOT OF
ADS, THE PRESIDENT DOUBLING
DOWN ON THE FEAR, CRIME, MAKING
MS-13 INTO THE NEW BAD GUY
THAT'S COMING TO GET YOU AND
YOUR FAMILY.
THAT IS INTENDED JUST TO HIS
BASE.
BUT IT IS NOT AMONG THE TOP
ISSUES RIGHT NOW.
HEALTHCARE REMAINS
OVERWHELMINGLY THE TOP ISSUE.
THE NUMBER TWO ISSUE IS THE
ECONOMY, NUMBER THREE, I THINK
THIS IS ONE THAT REALLY TOUCHES
ME.
PEOPLE CONSIDER MULTILEVEL
DIVISION.
>> THAT WAS NUMBER THREE IN THE
POLL.
>> WHAT YOU SEE IS LIKE WHEN
THE PRESIDENT WENT TO
PITTSBURGH.
RABBI MEYER, WHEN HE WAS
MEETING WITH HIM, HE SET THE
SHABBAT SERVICE YESTERDAY
PITTSBURGH.
HE SAID, I SAID TO THE PRESENT
THAT HATE SPEECH LEADS TO HATE
ACTION.
AND WHAT TOOK PLACE IN THE
SANCTUARY.
I THINK LOTS OF AMERICANS ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE POOR
QUALITY OF HATEFULNESS WE ARE
SEEING IN THE COUNTRY AT THE
MOMENT.
>> AND THOSE ACTUALLY BOTH
SIDES THAT WILL READ ABOUT
THAT.
TAMMY, LET ME GO TO YOU.
SOME OF THESE RACES ARE TIED
LIKE THE ONE IN MISSOURI.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS GOING TO HIS
FINAL CAMPAIGN RALLY ON MONDAY
NIGHT AT 9 PM IN MISSOURI.
YOU THINK WILL BE ENOUGH TO TIP
THIS INTO THE FAVOR OF JOSH
HAWLEY?
>> IS TRYING TO NATIONALIZE THE
RACE.
THIS IS WHAT WILL MAKE THE
REPUBLICANS HAVE A BETTER DAY.
HIM GOING TO EVERY SINGLE ONE
OF THE STATES.
HE HIMSELF, NATIONALIZE DIPPY
NEWT GINGRICH BROUGHT TOGETHER
THE CONTRACT FOR AMERICA.
OBAMA DID IT WITH OBAMACARE.
YOU KNOW, NOT TOO OFTEN.THE
PRESIDENT HIMSELF HAS BEEN THE
NATIONALIZE REPAIR BUT IT'S NOT
HIS RHETORIC REGARDLESS OF EVEN
HOW TIGHT THE STATE IS OR NOT.
HIS RHETORIC IS NOT ABOUT FEAR
MONGERING.
HE IS REFLECTING WITH THE
AMERICAN VOTER ALREADY FEELS.
AS AN EXAMPLE, SINCE HE PERCENT
OF VOTERS BELIEVE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION IS A MAJOR PROBLEM.
THAT WAS IN AUGUST.
70 PERCENT SAY STRICTER
ENFORCEMENT OF IMMIGRATION LAWS
IS NECESSARY.
THAT WAS JUNE AND A POLE.
THE PRESIDENT IS REFLECTING
BACK WHAT AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
REALLY CARE ABOUT AND WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THEIR LIVES ARE
SAFER.
IT'S NOT THAT WE ARE AFRAID, IS
THAT YOU NOTICE WHAT'S GONE
WRONG AND YOU WANT TO FIX IT.
SO THE PRESIDENT'S PRESENCE
WILL FIND WILL MAKE A HUGE
DIFFERENCE.
AND OF COURSE IF IT MATTERS
FLORIDA HAS MATTERED A GREAT
DEAL.
NELSON AND SCOTT.
WE'LL FIND OUT HOW IT WORKS AND
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS ARE
MAKING A MISTAKE IN THINKING
THAT THE NEW ENTHUSIASM ONLY
BELONGS TO THEM.
THEY THOUGHT THEY HAD THEM AT
60 WITH HILLARY AND THEY WERE
MISTAKEN.
>> I DO THINK BECAUSE WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT FEAR MONGERING,
THAT THE OTHER SIDE IS GETTING
HUGE FREE PASS ON THIS.
WHEN I SEEN AS IT IS SAID THAT
REPUBLICANS, LET'S FACE IT, FOR
DECADES NOW, REPUBLICANS HAVE
BEEN ACCUSED OF DESTROYING THE
ENVIRONMENT.
GOING AFTER SOCIAL SECURITY,
TAKE YOUR HEALTHCARE.
NOW IT IS ENSLAVING WOMEN AND
PUTTING CHILDREN IN CAGES.
THAT'S A NEW THING.
HANDMAIDS TALE.
SETTING UP CAMPS ARE VERY
REMINISCENT OF A IMPASSE.
ALSO LET'S NOT FORGET THE
DEMOCRATS PIONEERED THE
NEGATIVE ADS WITH THE DAISY AD,
THE NUCLEAR WINTER AGAINST
GOLDWATER.
I THINK SAYING THAT THE FEAR
MONGERING IS ON ONE SIDE, IS A
LITTLE BIT OF A STRETCH.
>> LET'S GO BACK TO THE CURRENT
THING.
I WILL LEAVE GOLDWATER TO YOU
BUT IT'S INTERESTING TO ME THAT
THE PRESIDENT CHOSE IMMIGRATION
AS THE FOCUS BECAUSE THE
ECONOMY WASN'T WORKING FOR HIM.
IN THE LATEST POLLS, WHAT WE
SEE IS AMONG ALL VOTERS, 47 bÃ